[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them Baker
[Music]
it appears that the Russians tried to
convince us that the ukrainians
attempted a assassination on Vladimir
Putin at the Kremlin while he wasn't
there
oh this is so ridiculous did you see the
footage
as it couldn't even it couldn't even
take out the flag on the top of the
building come on man you don't actually
believe this [__] do you I mean really
honestly if if someone like Ukraine was
gonna try to take out a building that
Vladimir Putin was in they wouldn't
send a drone that farts on it I mean
that I mean yeah there was an explosion
but Khan man come on
Putin listen man just eat your ammo
sandwich already it's over you're
obviously acting in desperation so that
you can intimidate the ukrainians in the
Ukrainian president zielinski
it's I mean you know this is just my
opinion
but come on
I've watched the videos this morning
and if you watch and I'm gonna show them
to you of course
but this is ridiculous man
this is this is worse than when this is
this is
Trump is better at fraud than this guy
oh my God it's so obvious
how in the hell do we have such
nincompoop authoritarians in this world
like it's not even it's not even a good
attempt
I mean if they wanted to convince us
that Ukraine was trying to kill Putin at
least have him in the building while the
Drone you know kind of farts near it or
or if he's not in the building bomb that
[__] or something just try to
convince us of something
I mean it really honestly it looks like
a drone did a you know those uh m80s
that you get in the fireworks stand you
know what I'm talking about I think
they're outlawed now when we were kids
we used to get these m80s
um and they were like little little
Miniatures Dynamite sticks and we'd have
like bottle rocket Wars and them any
wars I mean we'd throw those some
[__] at each other when they were lit
yeah listen it was the [__] 90s what
are you gonna do
hahaha
but here's the thing is it looks like
the Russians loaded up a drone with a
bunch of m80s and tried to set the flag
on top of the building on fire and they
couldn't even get that accomplished
yeah man
it's it's insanity
I don't know maybe it's just me maybe
it's just me
um
boy someone's pointing out that I have
pink guys again I was I did not drink
last night
I I don't I don't know it could be I'm
just a little tired maybe didn't have
enough coffee hell I don't know hell I
don't know you you decide
just like with the Vladimir Putin faking
his assassination you [__] you watch
the video you decide whether they're
faking it or not come on man
okay
Vladimir buddy Vlad come on just make
the ammo sandwich and eat it already
you're done you're finished it's over
the world's against you you suck your
army sucks your military sucks half your
military doesn't even want to be where
they're at they don't even know why
they're there half your half your
oligarchy contractors want to kill you
in the first place because they want the
power grab come on man this is what
happens to authoritarians
when we have murderous dictators
who try to invade Sovereign Nations and
tried to strip away the freedoms of
their people and other and people in
other countries it doesn't end well for
them
it does not end well for them
I mean we talk about the Republican rake
steppers here in in this country but
authoritarians are always the biggest
rake steppers in history always they
always
can't find enough [__] rakes to step
on can't find enough political and
economic Graves to bury themselves in
and it's not it's not like um uh set in
stone
but look this is what this this is what
Humanity leads to when you Corner them
and cage them in authoritarianism that's
why people are [__] yelling and
screaming and shouting in this country
we watched yesterday in the Texas
capital
where people who were protesting were
[__] rough towels and and arrested
for what being loud get the [__] out of
here with this nonsense
and and you wonder why people in this
country are upset about January 6 where
people were breaking in Windows roughing
up police officers trying to overthrow
our government and they just ran them
off with with a bunch of pepper spray
and
and flashbangs come on the [__] out of
here
no one no one is believing the nonsense
that we should slow row into
authoritarianism I mean we watched a
video yesterday of police officers being
set on fire in France because they're
raising the retirement age two years
two years they're taking away the people
of Francis Liberty of being retired and
they're like [__] no we're gonna set
cops on fire
foreign s do not like when you take
their Liberty away from them I mean
unless they're [__] brainwashed and
mind [__] like they are here in this
country by Christianity and white
Christian nationalism
because that's what's happened here
come on man we listen yes is
authoritarian on the rise in in this
world sure but people are getting wise
to it minute after minute after minute
and it's not gonna go well for them I
don't give a [__] about social media and
the problems that we have with
misinformation you know you can you can
yell and scream about that all you want
but the fact remains there are humans on
this planet
and The Human Condition is always what
is at the Forefront with humans
that's just how it's gonna [__] work
just like Rhonda Santos thought that he
was gonna go out in the nation and sell
this wilkism [__] go woke go broke
anti-woo you dumb [__] you don't
even know what you're talking about
and no one gives a [__] about what
you're saying they got other [__]
problems to worry about that what
someone else is wanting to dress in or
where or what their sexual orientation
is or who they want to love and marry no
one gives a [__] about that
they got more of their own problems
and you're and you're worried you're
worried about what the [__] Bible
does or doesn't say about other people
and how you're gonna oppress them based
on your stupid [__] book
and you're stupid [__] delusion come
on you think Americans buy that [__]
get the [__] out of here
I'm here to tell you that this is all
just a bunch of
faked nonsense just like the Drone
attack on the Kremlin
same [__] different diaper folks
it's like the Bud Light thing I know
they continue to talk about the Bud
Light thing as if Bud light's gonna go
out of business Bud Light is not a
company you dumb [__]
mbev owns the Anheuser-Busch Brands
Anheuser-Busch has [__] dozens
hundreds of Brands you stupid [__]
stop being such a dumb [__]
stop
pluck your head out of your ass and
realize you're being duped by a bunch of
[__] oligarchs
who want you to do their bidding
in the culture war that no one cares
about no one gives a [__] about your
culture war no one wants to go to war
with people who just want to [__]
love who they want to love
no one I mean besides a bunch of [__]
Nazis
but it's the world we live in
authoritarian fraud oh my God I'm sorry
you know a lot of people are [__] you
know all right oh this is serious stuff
listen they're not serious people
this is not serious they're not serious
people
you think Vladimir Putin is a serious
person after what we what we View
as a blatant attempt
to fake an assassination on him so that
they can continue
to press their Narrative of why the war
is Justified in Ukraine because that's
really the battle they're losing and
that's what they're going to lose
they're going to lose the Battle of why
they're there with the Russian people
and it's not going to go well for
Vladimir Putin it's not
you can't keep up a lie that long and
that big of a lie it's the same thing
with Trump being the nominee here in
this country almost every single member
of the Republican party does not want
Trump to be their nominee but he has to
be they have no choice because they're
too deep in the fraud they're too deep
into the LIE they can't unwind it [__]
them let them Crash and Burn Let Them
step on the rake let them face plant
don't take the shovel out of their hand
when they're digging their political
grave [__] them
[__] em [__] em [__] em and I'm here to
tell you we should be laughing
hysterically
at them flailing trying so desperately
to remain relevant have you watched
Rhonda santis
the clip of him lashing out right
reporters is [__] hilarious it's
hysterical
while they're questioning about his role
in torturing detainees at gitmo he says
they don't they how could they ever
remember me how could you forget a
[__] weirdo like that
come on
if you went to a different town in a
different [__] State one time and
walked in and met Rhonda Santas you
would remember that [__] weirdo you'd
be like yeah I remember that creep I
remember him being in that bar we only
had an interaction for about five
seconds but I remember that [__]
and to to think that detainees at gitmo
wouldn't remember the person who was
torturing them you were get the [__] out
of here with this [__] man
and Ronda santis in his act of lashing
out at reporters to get a story about
how he tortured detainees and they
remember him he wasn't like I didn't
torture anyone at gitmo he was like they
couldn't remember me when I was
torturing them there's no way
only admitting that he was doing it
and you don't think that's you don't
think that's [__] laughable that the
second person listen listen to me listen
to me this is hysterical
that the one person that they want
instead of the Cheeto dust q and honor
fell flat on his face with his stupid
[__] war on wokism whatever that
means
and now he's admitting that yeah I
[__] tortured people with gitmo you
don't think that's hilarious that that's
the guy they wanted to replace the
[__] idiot from Mar-A-Lago you don't
think that's [__] hilarious
listen folks 2024 is gonna be a big
election but the presidential election
is going to be a dunk
that's right it's gonna be a slam
[__] dunk
all we got to make sure is that we
politicize it in a way that's right we
need to politicize it in a way
that makes it a slam dunk what we need
to concentrate on right now is Senate
races house races and state government
races that's where we need to put our
[__] energy in take back the house
make sure we increase the Senate and
take back these super majorities in
these [__] state legislators take
them away from Republicans they're
destroying our [__] fabric of our
country
and yeah you would say oh well that's
the red States who gives a [__] it
matters it [__] matters
it's always the slow rule of fascism
don't let them [__] convince red
states that they should capitulate to a
bunch of [__] Nazis [__] that [__]
take the stance of of Justin Jones and
Justin Pearson and Gloria Johnson in
Tennessee and stand against this [__] in
red States these people in red States
aren't non-liberal they just don't know
what liberal means they don't know that
they've been duped by white Christian
nationalism yet
we're not done with democracy here in
this country we're not
and it's time we fight
with our democracy and using democracy
to defend it [__] them
and yeah if we can laugh at them and
mock them that's the best that's the
best scenario we could have
because it's [__] laughable
it's laughable I mean think about it man
think about it
didn't this video of this drone
attacking the attacking the Kremlin
whoosh
you didn't even sell it very good
you didn't
but here we are
here we are some other news some other
news
they caught the uh the the neighbor
murderer
down in Texas oh man again the plot
Slips Away from from these stupid
[__] gun nut boneheads they're like
oh
ow he was he was he was an illegal error
he was supposed to be deported then
why do you think we've been talking
about guns and access to guns you stupid
[__] oh well Tony he didn't buy it
legally yes you're not paying attention
you're not paying [__] tension
hell most of the guns that are used in
Mexico are manufactured here in this
country and taken across the border that
way
foreign
manufacturers give a [__] who who buys
the gun they don't give a [__]
hell they're passing laws all around the
country lobbying laws all around the
country where no one can give a [__] who
buys what gun when and where
so you think the gun manufacturers give
two shits
if the drug cartels are buying their
guns they don't give a [__]
do you think they give two shits
if a neighbor buys a gun and goes and
kills children and a family with it do
you think they give a [__] they don't
give a [__] all they care about is the
money that that gun made them they don't
care
you [__] break there's a handful of
families in this country that make all
the [__] money off manufacturing guns
prove me wrong prove me wrong you
[__] gun nuts go go ahead try it
there's a handful of families that own a
handful of companies in this country
that make the the majority of the
profits off gun Manufacturing
and getting them loose on our streets
and other streets around the world
that's what it is and they use our
[__] laws and our [__] legislators
and our [__] governments us us we are
the government it's our government they
use our government to make sure that
they pile these weapons on the street
of course he got a gun of course it was
easy for him to get a gun it was [__]
Texas
and if anyone from another state where
it's difficult to get a gun just drive
to Texas drive to Indiana drive to
Missouri it's damn easy drive to Florida
it's damn easy to get a gun
just try it go it's real [__] easy
and until until we realize what the
problem is with some [__] idiot
Who's Got a Gun
who can get a gun anytime anywhere he
wants because of the state he lives in
can walk across the yard and murder a
family of five then you're not
understanding the problem oh well he was
here illegally okay
so what you're not going to do anything
about that either well he was mentally
ill so what you're not gonna do anything
about that either
you [__] idiots
same old fake ass [__]
from the fake ass Nazis
the real American first Nazis who claim
their Patriots and claim they have
compassion get the [__] out of here you
are not pro-life you are you are not a
patriot you are a [__] traitor and
you love when children get mowed down
with weapons of war you could care less
because it's great profits for a handful
of families in this country and and the
gun lobby gives you a shitload of money
on top of it
I give you your cut
doesn't matter who this guy was it
doesn't matter why he was here it
doesn't matter if he could buy a gun
legally it doesn't matter if the gun was
illegal or legal or not it's Texas
they're all it's all it's a free-for-all
who gives a [__] you think you think
Greg Abbott gives a [__] of a gun's
legal or illegal give me a break he
doesn't give a [__]
and he really doesn't give a [__] which
gun is used to kill children as long as
they're using a gun and pumping profits
for his [__] donors
yeah I'll say it I don't give a [__]
I mean I think Americans are sick and
tired like I am I think they think the
way I do
I mean I'm just the one with the
microphone yelling and screaming into it
maybe
but hell that's why you come here every
[__] day is to get a cathartic
release especially in the first 30
minutes when I'm yelling and actually
yelling and screaming into a microphone
people are sick of this [__] this idea
that somehow this [__] nation is
conservative is [__] conservatism
doesn't exist in this country folks it
doesn't exist we have fascists and we
have people who believe in democracy to
some degree
and most people are liberal progressives
in this country I don't care how you
labor yourself you want to the country
to get better and you want more Liberty
for for everyone
a progressive liberal
hmm oh words oh oh words
so get loud
don't be scared of these [__]
chuckleheads
it's it's time it's time we engage in
our democracy in a way
that we can make those changes and yeah
it's not going to be the changes that
everyone wants
I don't align with every single person
on the left that's okay
we don't agree on every single point
that's okay
that's kind of the [__] point of
democracy that's kind of the point
but when democracy is at risk
we have to make sure we take care of the
[__] threat to democracy
and it's not hard we just have to pluck
our heads out of our ass
it really is not hard yes we're gonna
have plenty of delusional people it's
really easy to be delusional honestly I
could use a bit of delusion myself
frankly Jesus Christ having to walk
around looking at all this [__] knowing
what I know God damn
I mean that's one reason why I like
doing this show because it's not just
cathartic release for you it's cathartic
release for me to be quite honest
it's kind of my therapy or has become my
therapy
but I I know the majority of this
country wants Liberty for all people
wants equity and equality they don't
give a [__] about what someone else is
doing just leave them and their family
the [__] alone
look I don't care if you're a white
Christian nationalist I mean I'm gonna
point it out especially if you're gonna
say it out loud I'm gonna point it out
just like you're going to point out that
I'm a liberal oh my God I'm a liberal I
want people not to go broke because of
health care because of a medical bill I
want children to be educated oh my God I
want people to go to college without
having to work their entire lives to pay
off the debt I want them to get decent
pay when they get a job oh my God I'm a
liberal you want to legislate a group of
people out of existence
you're trying to ban Women's Health Care
do you see the [__] difference you
extreme Christian white nationalists and
frankly find whatever you want to do man
if you want to be a white Christian
nationalist go ahead be my guest I'll
point it out to you I'm gonna show you a
[__] Church in Springfield Missouri
it's wild [__] man I mean you talk about
a [__] cult whoo this white male
privilege fragile white male privilege
cult is something else I'm gonna show it
to you holy [__]
whoo man it's something
it's crazy [__]
and I'll point it out again I don't care
if you point out that I'm a liberal I
could give [__] less yeah you God
someone says they say libtard yeah you
call me libtard I don't give a [__] go
ahead whatever you want to do liberal to
me it's not a bad word
if you look up the [__] word just go
look up the [__] word
and then look up the word fascism and
see if it fits your beliefs dummy
fine if you want to be a white Christian
nationalist that's your Liberty in this
country to do it it's our Liberty to
point it out too it's our freedom of
speech to point it out
you're not going to get very far though
but what we have to do in this country
what we have to understand is we are the
[__] government we we the people are
the [__] government and we get to
decide who the [__] is in charge of
making decisions for us
at different levels
of our government whether it be city
council whether it be the [__] County
commissions school boards whether it be
state government or federal government
it's us to get to decide who the [__] is
up they're making the decisions and we
do not have to settle for a bunch of
white Christian nationalist mind [__]
delusional q and honors we don't
we don't have to bend our knee to white
supremacy in this country we do not have
to do that
we can tell them to go [__] off all the
way all the way off [__] them
and it's time we do that not just in
this next election but keep it going
and I'm telling you that if we can get
people to pay attention in this country
to the threat
of how they're going to undermine our
way of life in this country our freedom
our Liberty our rights
I'm telling you the majority of the
country is going to tell them to go to
hell
that's what the but we have to be loud
we have to be [__] louder than them
and I'm telling you
whoo boy
are they yelling and screaming a bunch
of BS I'm gonna again I'm gonna show you
this tape from a church
a church
in Springfield Missouri again you know a
lot of people like oh my God this is
dangerous blah blah I think it's funny
I think it's funny
it's funny it's hilarious that that that
they think that's gonna sell well in
this country that they think their ideas
are good ideas it's hilarious
the problem is the problem is it's us on
the left look at each other and we have
disagreements and what we what we don't
agree on is hey what we need to do is
get rid of the threat
and the threat is not liberalism the
threat is not it's not compromising
between the left and the left the the
listen the threat is not compromising
between what the minimum wage should be
folks
but the right doesn't even have a
position anymore on minimum wage they're
too hyper focused on genitalia and Who's
got what genitalia and who can is
allowed to have what genitalia and who
can wear a dress with what genitalia
what what what your names and race and
gender you could put in a cartoon
they're [__] out of their minds
they're lost it
they've lost the plot line of democracy
and it's up to us to get it back on
track and one way to do it is to tune in
every single weekday here at the Tony
Michaels podcast Newton Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch don't forget to subscribe to the
YouTube channel you're not going to want
to miss a single episode it's live live
live on YouTube also follow us on
Twitter at the Tony Michaels pod
download every single episode in the
afternoon after I get it edited and
posted on Apple Spotify Google it's free
99 over there it doesn't cost you a
thing I will ask that favor
to the audience every single day go
download the audio episode
I know you don't it's a lot but it would
help us out speaking of helpless that
you guys over on Twitch it's amazing I
can't even tell you how much Support
over on Twitch we've got listen we got
over a thousand followers which is free
to follow us on Twitch it doesn't cost
you a single nickel to go follow us on
Twitch if you download the app create uh
an account if you have an account on
Twitch go follow us it's free but you
guys have
it's overwhelming I can't believe how
many of you
decided to take your Amazon Prime
account because if you have an Amazon
Prime account you get one free
subscription on Twitch and you can
subscribe on Twitch it's it's one of the
freest ways to give the show monetary
support that's right you can give us
money and it doesn't cost you a nickel
if you're an Amazon Prime subscriber if
you have Amazon Prime you get one free
twitch subscription if you link your
Amazon Prime account in your Twitch
account you can give us that one free
subscription and 142 of you have that's
amazing I think we had I think we have
like 60 some
just last week we've over we've doubled
it so I'm setting a new goal 200
subscribers for prime prime subscribers
200 we're at 142.
so and it's again if you have a Prime
account already it's a free way to give
us money which is awesome another way
you can give support is go to the
upwire.com go to the up wires YouTube
channel follow the upwire YouTube
channel also if you're on Facebook you
can follow us there at the Tony Michaels
at the Tony Michaels on Facebook you can
watch us live there as well
I got some footage to show you Gabe
Sanchez is going to join us today I
think his internet problems are now over
so he'll be joining us here everyone
stick around don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
where shall we start today
[Music]
or you want to see a couple Republican
races
got some crazy [__] to show you
absolutely crazy and I know Gabe Sanchez
has a few topics that he wants to talk
about he's going to join us here in a
few minutes someone over on Twitch I
think was Big Stuff let me see if I can
find the comment here
I said I'll believe I'll believe Gabe
Sanchez has his internet problems
fixed when I see him
Ah that's hilarious here it is I believe
Gabe's internet problems are over when I
see him see it to believe it you know
that I'm in the show me state so I think
big big staff fan over there is saying
show me show me the money
Hell Boy now let's see should I do the
whole uh Springfield Missouri church
thing and I think I'll wait on that one
um I think I'll wait on that one let's
see what what else
um what other
there's a lot of rake stepping
um that's happening on the Republican in
of course oh by the way let's see if
I've got a message here
um for the uh we're supposed to get a
final draft
of our let's see rake uh design if you
want to see the the draft the first
draft of the let them eat rake design
you can go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels that's patreon.com the Tony
Michaels I posted it over there uh you
can see the the design of your patreon
member uh I give patreon the Early
Access to some of the content that we
make and then you get exclusive content
over there as well like ask me anything
and also
the Sunday rants go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels you can check out the let
them eat rake initial design I'm
supposed to get that today I know it's
we're going through several drafts with
the artist with the coloring and how it
looks so I'm I'm hoping in the next few
days we can release the merch and you
guys can I have at it and see the design
and then and then we'll release the
design on patreon so you guys can grab
the design and like post it online as a
meme or whatever
um and that way you guys can have fun
with it whether you want and maybe I'll
make some banners and some avatars uh
for you guys uh so you can do that and
also that some people have suggested
like hats or something which I don't
think we'll be able to put the character
on the hats for those who have seen it
on patreon but we'll probably be able to
put the let them eat rake on hats
um so I'm gonna be looking into that so
hopefully by the weekend we have
everything up and everything's going and
you guys can um use it how you want
and again I I think the audience for all
the great ideas and that just happens to
be one of the most popular
what Demi rake that's hilarious you guys
are great uh they are professional rake
steppers though let me show you uh um
because we got a Tucker Carlson rake
step here
oh my god did you see the text messages
I know Gabe Sanchez is going to talk
about that
um we have some I think Elon Musk is in
the news Stephen Crowder
um and made some news by showing his
genitalia to people I uh I guess
um Matt Walsh is simping for Tucker
Carlson so we'll look at that also CNN
did a huge rake step on the writers
strike because that's another piece of
news that's going on uh in this country
is the writers are on strike so you're
if you're watching network television or
any any kind of content at all that
requires writers it's gonna suck that's
why I'm excited maybe I'll attract a lot
of people we don't have writers here I
don't write this I mean I guess like
live I write it live but I'm not like
actually writing or typing I'm just it
it's it's all right off the cuff I don't
write any of this [__] okay uh let's see
oh oh um Jim Comer James Comer at James
q and honor I don't know if you know who
James is
he's he's Jim Jordan's little buddy
in Insurrection and Sedition uh James
Comer says that he has evidence that
Biden didn't break any laws and it's
questionable rather it's ethical or not
but he would wish it was the illegal he
wishes it was illegal there's another
rake to step on uh Lauren bobert
uh she can't tell a joke where the [__]
ah these fright Wingers just don't I
guess maybe the writer's strike is on
the right too what do you think Gabe
Sanchez do you think there's a problem
with the right having comedy because the
writers strike or do you think none of
the writers would actually write for him
that's why their comedy sucks what do
you think
um you know that's a good question I
honestly think uh that the simplest
answer is the right answer and that
being that the right wing media the the
right wing comedians are terrible at
comedy
um we know this right they're bad at
comedy because they're scared of it or
rather they're scared of it because
they're so bad at comedy they don't know
how to take self-deprecating humor they
don't know how to make a joke of
themselves they don't know how to take a
joke in any any sense and when they do
try self-deprecating humor it turns out
like this watch this this is [__] oh
it's cringe-worthy watch this
about Ted Cruz lately in the news
and contrary to popular to belief
I've never been an escort for Senator
Ted Cruz but I will tell you tonight it
is the coolest thing I've ever heard
about Ted Cruz
wow it even landed flat in the turning
points USA room they're like what what
it's they ouch I I saw so I saw that
clip yesterday and I was like wait did
she say it again I mean it's a resurface
clip right it go it goes to show you
that like even when they're like oh man
I'm gonna get those lips for that rumor
they spread about me being an escort
that slept with Ted Cruz for money for
my campaign and oh man I got them and
and and 10 times out of ten it is always
a [__] face plant right they step on
the rake and what ends up happening is
we just
I guess ironically laugh at them because
they're trying to be funny and it's like
no it's not funny it's the same way and
actually funny that you mentioned
what's going on right now and I'll have
to incorporate the writer strike into it
but like I'm doing it what was that
that's on the White House correspondent
Center but there's an overall theme
that's that's uh that I have written
throughout it which is
Republicans are terrible at comedy for a
variety of reasons
but the main reason they hate the White
House Correspondence Dinner is because
they don't know how to take a [__]
joke no and it's been that way for years
I mean just to give an example
Donald Trump is such a [__] [__] ass
[__]
okay
that after 2011 which some might say is
the origin story to him trying to run
for president because they [__] rag
on him hard because he came after Obama
in the birther movement right right and
then he showed up at the correspondence
dinner which made him even a bigger
Target right so they showed him up they
should he showed up at in the 2011
correspondence Center Seth Meyers Obama
and others [__] ragged on him
and then you fast forward
Trump becomes president in 2017 he comes
into office right he doesn't show up to
the correspondent Center then 2018 nope
2019 nope obviously 2020 was a pandemic
and then and that was it right he never
showed up to any of the times that he
was I wonder what it could be it was
probably a scheduling conflict
clearly that or it's maybe because he
tweeted that he's like oh that's not
done in good faith I think he's just a
cuck I think that's what it is he's a
cook I have to remember that that people
got real pissed off about Michelle
Wolf's joke about the smokey eyes
with the look on her face the look on
her face when she when she says that
line and the look on Sarah Huckabee
Sanders face I'm just like uh listen
normally a comedian when they're doing
jokes like that they want the recipient
especially if they're right there to
receive them with laughter but when she
receives it with the worst Grimace in
the world because it's the truth right
it's the truth and that's what comedy is
is about about the truth and speaking of
that there's been a story this week
there's been a little ignored
um but it's hard to ignore when someone
gets their genitalia it just it just is
yeah it's kind of hard to ignore that
but Stephen Crowder
um you know he's been going through um
his little divorce and and well he's
been playing victim I mean here look if
you were to read through his divorce
papers it's straight up victims like
that's the well he that's the language
what do you want I mean this this guy's
made a career off victimhood right like
the entire career is victimhood but here
he is so there's allegations which I'll
let you run through allegations I feel
like they're well right right well okay
okay I'll let you run through them but
Stephen Crowder in in um to try to get
out in front of this
he he tries to do a bit on his show and
in the bit up to try to to try to
um half-handed him showing his genitalia
to his employees on the set over and
over and over again because that's the
allegation right that he's showing his
genitalia to his employees and people
who work with him
he actually they make a bit where he
shows his balls to a guy on the show I'm
not [__] you I wouldn't [__] you're
my favorite hilarious oh it's hilarious
watch watch the here again here's
another example of how they suck at
comedy okay all right and that now
there's this newspaper article out this
morning where um it says quote Crowder
was known to expose his genitals to
stuff hold on a second yeah we'll do yes
just wait
I mean that did happen what are you
talking about the Terminator 2 sketch no
but at the time you only had five
employees and they were all male well
yeah I know but that was a Terminator
two sketch because remember the nudies
didn't fit oh did that one yeah well no
okay okay okay so I had to watch this a
couple times because I'm trying to
figure out what the hell's going on here
because I'm trying to figure out if this
is actually a bit because it's written
up to where it doesn't even seem like a
bit that's how bad they are at it but
here's here's the thing is that is that
he talks about how the nudies didn't fit
do you know what a nudie is yeah what's
a nudie tell the audience what a nudie
so a nudie and I'm assuming because I
haven't seen the sketch but I'm assuming
what they did was you have uh you can
also use it from from pantyhose you can
cut them up and do it that way because
I've done that on set as well which is
where basically you have something that
is skin colored matches your skin tone
and you use it to cover up your ass and
your front area whatever it might be
right so that you're not what so that
you're not what naked because you don't
want to show someone your [__] and
your gen the daily right right but also
the main reason is because typically for
some probably for this bit that they're
doing they want to have as much exposure
without being like Oh there's underwear
or also they're trying to do a blur and
trying to be like oh look he's naked
right like this all the time yeah yeah
he's not actually now in in Hollywood
when they're not shooting porn Okay
because porn porn has to have certain
disclosures and consent when you're when
you're no there there isn't there also
is a different there's a [__] sock too
yeah tell us what a [__] sock is hey
we're gonna do this let's make sure
okay a [__] sock is a skin colored I
mean essentially but it's a it's a it's
a sock and in its own way and you use it
to cover up your dick and your balls
right right so you're not showing them
right so again it's to have as much
exposure especially if you're having a
scene with an actress or an actor and
you're in bed or whatever it might be
right you know who probably know about
this but didn't do it so great is
Michael Knowles right Michael Knowles
would be a great person but he decided
to wear a um we should hey somebody
somebody get uh Michael nose on the line
we'll get him in here and we'll ask him
about uh nudies in a car so there's a
[__] suck right and then women also wear
um a skin colored uh it's kind of like
um it's like not not quite a patch but
like in the same sense of like a
Band-Aid right where it's like that type
of kind of look then there's also a
merkin right which is where which is
like the fake hair that women and men
can wear and stuff it's all these
different things that you can have
um in in in in scenes whatever it might
be definitely not porn because in porn
you're fully exposed right but in a
movie if you're in a thing and they're
like look we need to have you as exposed
as possible we need to make it look like
you guys are actually in the act of
having sex or in your bed together
whatever so okay uh chef Chef uh
boria homeboy how do I know so much
about this
because I've used similar things one set
before not I've never had to really I've
never had to wear [__] sack I've just
wear nudies you just know what a [__]
size yeah I know what it is and also
like every year like nudies or the [__]
sack which one you want no no I didn't
know oh okay no no I was like you know
because the stuff that I was doing they
were like oh we just need to make sure
that everything's not coming out you
know right we just don't want to see
your balls yeah we don't want to like if
you sit down with these boxers we want
to make sure that we can't see your
stick or your balls you know that kind
of thing so well and the other thing too
is a lot of times you know when you're
filming something you know you only have
so much you only have so much film right
and you know you want to inadvertently
catch a ball shot and then have to spend
money yeah make the ball shot out right
right or it doesn't cut right so you put
the [__] sack on or you put the nudies
on so that way you're just you're
covered like literally and in in the
actual editing yeah yeah you just want
to make sure that you're you know covers
it right yeah as Brendan Lewis says
your twigs and berries
so so here here is um
well let's continue this because they're
making this sound like what you're
saying right that these are sketches we
were filming this was all in good fun
right a lot of air quotes being around
those words there right exactly but
let's continue and see what happens here
oh there are the ET ones uh through the
corn fields where we had to run naked
together naked in that one yeah we were
naked in that one that was the night
though was it gay Captain America
because what happened is the cold the
the onesie didn't fit so we just had to
make it a nosy and there was no
um well now that there are ladies that
here we have to run things differently
this isn't like the Terminator clip well
I know it's not like the Terminator clip
do we have well yeah there's do we have
the Terminator
yeah okay
foreign
[Music]
okay so this is this is hilarious that
he thinks he's the Terminator right yeah
that's that's insane is did he do that
sketch before or after he did the
elective surgery on his chest I have no
idea probably after right I mean he
would have to after like he did he
probably thought he looked like too much
of a cuck yeah I need to look like the
Terminator I need the boob job
get me the surgeon uh but yeah it's it's
definitely
I don't know maybe maybe he did the
sketch and people were like oh what are
those [__] moves over there dude
that's probably what it was that's what
it was I gotta cut him I gotta cut him I
gotta reduce the fat that's probably
what it was is he got insecure about the
comments about the Terminator sketch but
let's go let's see what he let's see the
the punch line of the bit here of where
he's kind of in the news about showing
his genitalia forcing his genitalia on
his staff member [__] okay of course yes
many people saw my balls well yeah but I
had a sock on because annuities wouldn't
fit you couldn't do it yeah right yeah
you have a large posterior yes exactly
and there were also times where we
played this spot the balls just like
he's got huge picks right right right
exactly right I wonder what it is the
annuities didn't fit right because he
says he's got a big arrows uh he said
the nudies didn't fit so he had to wear
a sock and that's referring to the [__]
socks right earlier okay let's let's
let's keep going let's see what the the
punch line is here for this bit how he's
trying to
half ham it with the him showing people
his balls yeah well uh we need to stay
on topic as well okay
continuing with the infractions Riley
said quote govern Me Harder daddy Riley
oh
Riley said that these aren't all that
bad uh I mean I think I wouldn't get the
husband your mic isn't really working
all that well yeah I think wait it's
actually on a second the game uh here it
is right there
is that your testicle yeah it is
how funny how funny you're in the news
for showing your staffers that your
testicles and then you write a bit where
you make make fun of it by showing
yourself you want to know how
cringe-worthy that is right oh yeah I
all saw where this was going if you
didn't
I'm sorry you just don't don't use your
don't don't use right wing comedy as
your source of how are they gonna
[__] play this one out but this was
so predictable in the sense that they're
like oh we're gonna talk about it and
then we're gonna show it right but also
the ability for for Steven Crowder and
what made it even more was more
cringe-worthy is the fact that he like
scooched up his chair and he's like and
he like looks off screen
and gives it and again like [__]
signs it away to the to his little
co-host off to the side there where he
says where he's like like you can see
his head turn and he kind of smiles and
smirks to be like I'm gonna [__] show
my balls right and probably not even
show him his balls and I also feel like
at the angle that we saw it looked like
he was wearing pants that's not to say
you couldn't put your ball out of your
pants right but if the joke really was
gonna be good you [__] go for the
whole thing right well here's the thing
is that I don't know get up and then
you're nude right there would be a whole
thing right I don't know if you noticed
but there was one of his female
producers or on the show standing at a
mic yeah um and she in the bit they
wrote for her to leave it's all written
this isn't this is all [__] written
up now it's not by writers you're gonna
strike because these aren't actually
real writers they're [__]
chuckleheads right but they're not real
comedy writers also anyone also I just
want to say anyone who is part of wga
and crosses the line you are not
supporting the writers right that's why
people who are writers for Gutfeld are
going to continue to write for Gutfeld
because they're [__] scabs and they
don't support unions and they don't
support uh collective bargaining and
they don't support I mean look they
don't support they don't even sell the
living wage what I want to what I want
to say about this is if people don't
know about what's going on with the
writer strike you should definitely look
into it because basically What's
Happening Here is writers since 2007
2008 which is before streaming came out
right they renegotiated we went for like
100 or so days and a lot of the shows
that you may have loved during that
period came back and they [__] [__]
the bed it's because of the writer
strike a lot of shows actually failed
because of the writer strike and ended
up not having the same turnout in
audience numbers that it Formed that it
did before the writer strike so they got
the they they rewrote they negotiated
the contracts they got what they wanted
fast forward we've had streaming we've
had other services different things I
mean we've had since the pandemic movies
that have released on streaming
specifically haven't had those those
Clauses written into contracts and
actors have been [__] over in terms of
what the the the Box numbers were
supposed to be and what they had
negotiated before the movie came out
which was yes Scarlett Johansson got
really exactly she's like I'm not gonna
be the Black Widow anymore
my ass exactly I mean she was killed but
also like even if they were talking
about flashbacks
well they could have done a movie series
exactly there's a whole thing that could
have been done but they [__] her over
and they were like oh well this was all
based on the fact that it was going to
be a theatrical release but we had to do
it on uh we had to do it on streaming we
had to do it online because people
couldn't go into theaters people didn't
feel comfortable right and so
things were not negotiated for streaming
in place it was always used as the the
metric was box office in-person numbers
right and so when it comes to TV numbers
we noticed less and less people are
watching live TV but more and more
people are watching streaming because
again it's the ease and accessibility
you can watch wherever you want and
that's what's Happening Here is you've
got writers who are just trying to get
the [__] bare minimum just a a small
like one two percent is what the [__]
wage where you have people you have
people who have written for your your
your most favorite shows right that you
watch right now you're like oh that's it
that's that comedy is so funny or that
drama is so good or it's so [__]
emotional or whatever it is you have
this this group of people Executives
right and I'll actually pull up the clip
of Adam uh yeah I've got I've got it
Adam Conover I've got a group on CNN I'm
gonna play that and so basically
planning on putting that up next awesome
and so basically yeah that's what you
have going on you have a bunch of
Executives and people in the studios who
aren't willing to just give their fair
share to the people who are the Genesis
to the concepts in the shows and the
movies that they're creating and making
money for you know and that's what's so
[__] about this right is like
I'm not part of the wga I haven't had
any written that's been like done like
that so obviously but I I hold with them
in solidarity in terms of like you know
hoping that they get what they want to
get negotiated for which is just the
[__] bare minimum it's acknowledge
these people for the work and the effort
that they contribute into the [__]
Pockets that you give them right let me
let me let me say something else before
we get to this clip because Adam's gonna
point it out but it's also the disparity
in pay the disparity in pay so um let's
let Adam do it on CNN Adam Conover was
on CNN here's the interview that run
changing we are not making money as we
once did this is not the Golden Era of
Television although some of this would
argue the shows are great
um what do you say to them
so I'd point out the fact that David
zoslav the CEO of Warner Brothers
discovery which is you know the parent
company of the network I'm talking to
you on right now was paid 250 million
dollars last year a quarter of a billion
dollars that's about the same level as
what 10 000 writers are asking him to
pay all of us collectively so did you
catch that so 250 million dollars is is
the CEO of the parent company of CNN
Time Warner and that is that is the
amount that 250 million dollars that one
person get is what basically 10 000
writers are asking for that's the amount
one person got it in compensation 10 000
people are saying we just want you to
divide up that amount of compensation
between 10
000 of us that's all they're asking for
it's nothing hard it's like look man I
came up with the idea and we pitched it
and you guys bought it
and without us you wouldn't have the
other follow-up seasons in the in the
cult following or whatever it might be
like we are the ones who create these
Concepts if it was up to you you would
probably throw it into [__] chat gbt
and say write me a pilot for a show
about friends living in New York City in
an apartment right like you it's like
well I have another friends but I think
that's one thing that I think that's one
thing the writers are fighting for is is
their careers because what I mean by
that is the creativeness of their
careers because what's at stake here
um not just for the writers themselves
but also for the people who view the
content you the audience is that there
is possibility with AI
uh for Studios to hire writers that will
just rework uh artificial intelligence
like chant GPT so in other words they'll
train chat chat gbt to write shows and
then they'll hire writers to rework
championships these jokes can you
connect the plots right ABC plots right
yeah and and and that's not going to be
I mean obviously it's not going to be
good for the creativity of the writers
but it's also it's going to create [__]
content for the audience right um and
and if they decide to do this across the
board then then it's going to be bad
yeah yeah it's just going to be
available in in in the interim what
we're gonna have is like No One's Gonna
Have late night shows right they're
gonna play reruns so Jimmy Fallon Jimmy
Kimmel uh Seth Meyers uh Last Week
Tonight which are all written which are
all written by the creative funny
writers exactly like Steven Universe
shows that they made with the writers
because they can't make them right
without them exactly like you have these
people who who you know and and a lot of
those I mean it's a lot of the
inspiration that I have for the what was
that show that I do and a lot of the
reason why I do the what was that show
is just to have this like catharsis to
laugh off this crazy [__] timeline
that we're in
and obviously I can't do it on a nightly
basis so it's like you know props to
them and the team what you can't write
that kind of show every single day I
can't as one I cannot as one person if
people don't know this one person is me
I write it I research I write it I film
I edit and then I release it right
that's what I do as one person now they
have teams of writers that do that that
write the whole show wait you're saying
you're saying that Seth Meyers doesn't
write his entire show you mean that he I
mean he might write he writes some jokes
but the rest of it is you're saying he
doesn't write the entire thing I thought
he got up in the morning wrote the whole
thing put it on cue cards then he got
dressed by himself did his own makeup
set up the stage got the band ready by
himself I'm sure
you might you might think that any of
those late night comedians do that every
day they get up in the morning they
don't even see their families they just
sleep at the studio they're just the
host and the personality see I'm so used
to
running the show by myself I don't know
maybe Seth could you know anyways you
know the the one the one crazy part
about the whole thing is the the writer
strike is that the studios are going to
let the strike happen and the reason why
is because they're gonna make a shitload
of money off this because they have a
backlog of content that was already
written that they're going to err on
these platforms that they'll be able to
go two three four we it depends on the
show and the content but they'll be able
to sustain this and they're not gonna
have to pay anyone in the meantime yeah
so they're gonna make it the studios
stand to make a shitload of money on
this strike which is kind of interesting
and and I think it's the one reason why
um why it's so important that that
people understand why they're striking
and then the solid area that stands with
them uh let me finish this clip by Adam
Conover
uh here and I also want to show you a
quick clip of Rob Lowe uh marching in
solidarity that Rob Lowe marching in
solidarity with the writers which is uh
also interesting as well but let's
listen right so I would say if you're
being paid 250 million dollars Ted
serendos made about 50 million last year
uh these companies making enormous
amounts of money their profits are going
up it's ridiculous for them to plead
poverty when the writers who are making
their shows some of them are not able to
pay their rent or their mortgages I
literally know writers who have had to
go on assistance uh because they have
not been able to make their year uh the
the if you if you look at these
companies they're making more money than
ever it's the people who make the shows
for them that are making less
Adam coniber thank you so much for
coming on because you ruined everything
you may have just ruined my career but I
don't mind uh appreciate you coming on
so Adam's Adam's show is called Adam
ruins everything so well no not anymore
well he he doesn't have it I I don't
believe he has it on TV anymore I think
it was canceled now he just does a
YouTube uh he has a YouTube channel
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah well he did it
excuse me he did everything but he also
he also did a Netflix series here
recently
um that Obama's production company
produced and I forget the name of it and
I watched some of it um and he it's kind
of funny especially the uh the first
episode where there's the back and forth
between him and Obama of course Obama's
uh hilarious especially when Obama's
written for right because we all know
another example I mean that's the big
difference between Democrats and
Republicans is the ability to know how
to take a joke there's a key component
if you were to look inside biologically
genetically just inherently inside
Republicans and Democrats you'd be like
oh the main difference between these two
groups of people is empathy right
empathy understanding when to laugh what
to laugh at and knowing oh look if I
laugh at myself it indicates the others
that I'm one of them I'm willing to take
a jab I can laugh it off I can brush it
off no like it leads to leadership
skills lowering anxiety uh it also just
shows that you're just a [__] good
person right well it is true it is true
uh everyone we have a special guest
there's something going on in Texas that
I think she wants to talk about we've
had her on a few times
um Dara right I'm gonna get it right
Dara Bay is gonna no
I don't even get it right when I'm
trying to get it right what the [__] man
it's like you know here's what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna go to commercial when we
come back
I'm willing to consider that I'm willing
to make that consideration I'm not gonna
guarantee that I'm Gonna Change My Mind
If you think I'm just gonna guarantee
they'll change my mind will I know I
will you know where you can go the fact
that you listened that's right as long
as my [__] mind is open to the
possibility of not being an [__]
I'm still an [__] just considering
not being so yeah yeah everyone it's
like you know baby steps that's right
that's right everyone stick around we'll
get to the bottom of this name calling
and what the real names are when we come
right back right after this
[Music]
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
yeah
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
well it was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam jams skull
near run out Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one in
your absence I discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[Music]
[__] um
we're back back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I'm gonna get it right
I'm not that much of an [__] I mean
unless you're a republican then I'll
intentionally get that [__] wrong like
Matt gets it's not Gates it's not
spelled Gates God damn it it's gets Matt
gets
but right now we have a special guest
with us she's going to tell us about
what's going on in Texas
um crazy and [__] yeah go ahead yeah
okay yes yes
give me the name thing let's do it all
right go ahead uh it's Dara
Dara Dara I I say Dara we can bring my
mother on one day you know what what is
she what does she say what does she
saying what is she called Sarah
oh I I thought you're gonna say she
calls you something else no you should
hear you should hear what people call me
oh my God you should hear what I mean
Tony is a difficult one to play that t
is real hard to pronounce something when
I was younger my grandma would always
she would you know she would write out
the birthday card and she would be like
t-o-n-i right and I was like Tony
Collette okay yeah well and a lot of
people like oh it's a girl's name I'm
like well it's the same name as just
spell the different ways some girls
spelled that way but it didn't ever
offend me I'm just like 45 degree angle
line just hit the eye right there right
well it was like it's like happy 12th
birthday it's like you've done this 12
times and you still she was trying to
probably make that nickname happen
Anthony so she's like I don't like that
why
yeah yeah it could be it could be well
here's the other thing I think well I'll
just say this at least you don't have a
name like Gabe that was years of trauma
where people be like oh well full name
Gabriel and people be like oh Gabrielle
Gabby
and then the the one that stuck for I
don't know probably until fourth grade
or so maybe fifth grade if there was a
kid that really wanted to to put push
push my [__] buttons uh would say
Gabe and then he would be like oh man
your name's so gay and I was like oh God
wow she got annoying after like the
second grade it feels like you're still
a little a little salty over here I mean
as you know developing growing up as a
kid and you've got people that are using
your name against you it's not always
great you know especially try dealing
with Tony Baloney okay that my whole
[__] life it's Tony Baloney Tony
Baloney Tony Baloney and I say it's
balogna look at how you spell the word
it's bologna I'm just saying I'm just
saying it's not baloney tune anybody out
if they're trying to talk to you yeah
pretend you don't hear it right right
well let's talk about Texas because what
that I mean there's some crazy [__] in
Texas
um all the time but there's something
specific you wanted to talk about today
that they're training they're wanting to
train third graders right is that what
they're wanting to do they're wanting to
train them to do something educate them
but educate them do something really
weird it's almost like they're grooming
them I don't know
Okay so
can't remember the bill
or eleven people pull up that tweet Gabe
and now what I'll put it on there so so
this tweet from yesterday is it the
tweet I think you're putting of that guy
yeah yeah okay one from Mark um yeah go
okay so this bill just to give
background because I I made videos on it
yesterday so people would to bring more
attention to it but the bill was
originally written and I think put into
in it start I think it went into
um
what is it called when you start doing a
bow it's morning you guys you should do
the show committee no when it actually
goes into it doesn't matter they wrote
the Bill or it was passed in like
December of 2019 and then they started
actually like implementing it I guess in
in January of 2020.
um then what you see here see right here
where it says um it's crossed out seven
and then they updated it to three uh for
the grades okay so that is the revision
that was just proposed I believe this
past December and then this in like
March it passed like it hasn't been it's
still proposed it hasn't like passed
into law yet
um but they like updated it and it was
actually proposed by a Democrat and the
whole point was because they wanted to
get people to pay attention to no
Republicans to have like a conversation
which is when you when you live in the
onion you can't expect that Republicans
are going to be like this is ridiculous
they're gonna go for the weird [__] and
here we are and so this bill not only
wants bleeding control stations which
when I first saw that I honestly was
like oh is that what the south is
calling those tampon dispensers in
bathrooms but then like I kept reading
and I realized
oh wait wait wait wait I can't I can't
no no we can't Breeze over there so you
you think yeah
they've sent me that tweet and I didn't
read it and just I saw a bleeding
control station I was like [__] yourself
so you think you think in the South
there's in like women's restrooms
there's a you're talking about the
tampon stations that you put the
quarters in right and they and it's a
tampon right that's when I go I'm dampen
I don't yeah clearly um
you think on the on the machine it says
bleeding control station is that what
you I mean it makes sense if you think
about it right [__] means it feels
like it's not outside of their
wheelhouse okay well that makes sense
I'd be like let's call it what it is
like right give it a different name
we'll just write literally what it is or
describe it yeah well Mark Mark Elliot
here let me let me read the tweet and
then we'll we'll talk more about it says
here's what's going on in Texas on lunch
later in response to school shootings
okay so this is their solution uh to
children being ripped apart by a weapon
of war with high-powered rounds of
ammunition all students in third grade
and up to be trained in quote
Battlefield trauma care now that was
word that's not like him exaggerating
those words are in the actual bill is
that right
um yeah sorry your chat distracted me
apparently there's a active shooter in
Atlanta right now
well that is not surprising that we are
on the air talking about this and
there's an active shooting in the sky I
mean you know I'm serious yeah that's
not a surprise that this uh our country
is a hellscape of [__] weapons and
people just mowing down other human
beings just because of the the white I
call it the white gun culture in this
country
um but it's the guns you dummy it's the
guns it's not the bleeding control
stations are training elementary
students in Battlefield
trauma care and literally it's in the
bill here it is
um if you go to D it says a bleeding
control station or required under the
section must contain all of the
following required supplies in
quantities determined appropriate by the
superintendent of the school district or
a director of the School Number One
tourniquets approved for the use in
Battlefield trauma Care by the Armed
Forces of the United States now folks I
don't know if you if you are catching
when I say weapons of war but in Texas
the Republicans are like yeah that
sounds like a good idea let's make sure
all the tourniquets that we train a
third grader to use after their mowed
down by weapons of war are approved by
the armed first forces of the United
States go ahead well here's here's the
thing so I don't do you have the whole
bill opened are you this is just this is
just that okay so above that they they
specify how
um they need like trained personalities
okay Gabe I sent you a thing too did you
guys okay I got I got the one
um
so uh like school resource officers and
whatever other staff in the school that
they want trained which I see some flaws
in that first of all that's assuming
that these people are surviving to help
the children
um and also like not not to help any any
Mass Shooters out but like if you're a
mass shooter and you see this bill and
now you know what the schools are doing
to prep and you are going to kill like
you're going in and your point is not
you have one specific Target it's you
want to hit as many people as possible
first of all knock out the bleeding
stations and get the get the adults
first I mean this is it doesn't really
it's like it's Placebo to me this is
like a Band-Aid with like literally
literally a Band-Aid like literally like
really crappy adhesive that's not gonna
right though like literally Band-Aids is
what they're like oh oh there's a
problem with people going in schools and
murdering children in Mass because we're
going to enable the gun lobby and a
handful of families that own the gun
manufacturers to profit out the blood of
children you know what what's actually
literally throw a Band-Aid on it let's
do that yeah it's it's it's also um the
I mean like it goes to I mean if we if
we think back to Uvalde right there was
that there's a story of that girl who
had to pretend to be dead yeah she had a
white blood she had a white blood from
her dead from her dead classmate friend
person that she's known probably since
she was you know younger I forgot what
grade she was in or how old she was but
uh the idea that you have to then say
hey look kids look the life is crazy
shit's happening we don't know what's
gonna go on so you need to prepare it in
any way possible so if there's a shooter
that comes in the building we've got
these stations ready to go so you can
sew up and Stitch someone because if
your teacher's dead then it's all up to
you and if everyone else is dead and you
need to survive and you're the only one
left then you're going to take that
blood of your friend and your classmate
put it on your body and act I mean like
it's almost it reminds me of that scene
from Predator with Arnold Schwarzenegger
where he's like I gotta hide from the
from the predator and he puts on the mud
to um
to cool down his body for like the
thermal readings like that's what it
feels like you're in that type of War
Zone area you're using Battlefield like
training and supplies to be like okay
good luck surviving this and it's like
what the [__] are we doing like we think
what are they stitching up exactly the
right like the bullet wounds from these
weapons I right I ripped your [__]
arm it rips it it rips an adult's arm
off and it tears apart yeah you're not
putting pressure on that to stop the
bleeding no tourniquets stopping also
like a small child you're like that the
unfortunate reality is like any bullet
wound or or gunfire that happens on a
child like you you've got a kid that's
probably a third the size of an adult
which you're talking about you know not
as much blood more susceptible to
something going wrong and then it's just
it's insane to think that Republicans
are even like yeah you know what we
should lower even the fact that it was
at seventh like was at the seventh grade
to begin with right and then then uh
being totally open and be like yeah we
should make it younger right and even
though even though you said it was it
was brought up by a Democrat like
it's like no we shouldn't we should but
but I think what you're saying is the
Democrat brought it up to to make it
even more ridiculous and they're like
hey that sounds like a great idea right
well like let me let me read the part
never take the extreme because they're
gonna they're gonna accept it
wholeheartedly here's the part you were
talking about it's number three and the
bill will require the uh agency approved
training on the use of bleeding control
station in the event of injury of
another person to provide it to uh it
says each district uh peace officer
which would be like a school resource
officer SRO which is what they're called
in most uh places or security Now each
school resource officer again there so
so in other words there's the difference
between a a commissioned officer and
then a hired officer it depends on the
school and then all district or School
Personnel who may be reasonably expected
to use oh my God to use the bleeding
control station you can't make this [__]
up and then number four is the one we
were we've been talking about required
the district or Charter School to
annually offer not require not you know
um pushing on him you don't want to jam
this stuff you don't want to jam the
bandages down their throat right
um offer instruction uh on the use of
bleeding control stations from the
school resource or appropriate District
school Personnel who receive the
training so we're training the trainers
here
um and uh two students enrolled in the
campus in grade three marked out seven
or higher so grades three and higher are
going to be three notes wasn't it the
school resource officer in uh Parkland
at uh didn't they just like fault their
hightail their ass out of there well I
mean think about this think about it
typically goes if you're a slow resource
officer more than likely you're at the
end of your career okay I mean that
that's just this pure simple fact number
one you probably can't fit uh um uh uh
pass a lot of PT uh expectations a lot
of those school resource officers are
older our older officers they've been on
the job for a long time a lot of them
are only carrying a sidearm they're not
carrying rifles or shotguns because why
would we want why would we want security
officers carrying fully automatic
weapons in our schools I mean geez
Louise what what are they prisons now
it's almost like people are trying to go
into classrooms and mow down people but
here's the thing is that when when you
are faced in a situation as a human
um especially if you've never faced fire
before and someone has not one but two
semi-automatic rifles and several
semi-automatic handguns and all you got
is a couple clips and and a handgun
you're likely to do the human thing and
fight or flight and most of the time
you're gonna flight
um their PE classes they're gonna have
to start teaching the kids to run in
zigzags well I mean they're already
trying to teach them how to be not only
to use tourniquets that are approved by
Armed Forces but chess seals third
graders are gonna do chest seals
compression bandages bleeding control
bandages space emergency blankets latex
free gloves it's a good thing to know
how to use that markers hey there we go
there's some education they keep the
kids that's to keep the kids busy the
markers and the scissors right right I
have to I found it really impressive
like yesterday I did a video on this and
I I hadn't actually read this like list
and I started reading it on the video
and I realized like they really took
allergies into consideration when
putting
when putting them together yeah can we
just say can we just say students are
allergic to high-powered rounds coming
out of semi-automatic rifles because we
say that could we just say that's an
allergy yeah I mean
their their solution to that will be
that list will include epipens and stuff
right that's probably true yeah you know
yeah yeah I mean I I I I can't wait it
depends in Benadryl I I would I would
almost go out on a limb and say that if
someone were to say hey you know what I
have an amendment to this new Amendment
right
we should have blood ready at the school
like if we introduced a blood bank in a
freezer they'd be like oh yeah let's
let's [__] call up you know you know
start learning how to do catheters
exactly they're like okay so I have to
use a butterfly type uh yeah needle and
I've got to make sure that I hit the
vein oh nope miss it that time I'll get
it again on these little fingers you
know how sweaty they get like it's it's
the like I'm also thinking back to third
grade where I'm like okay third grade
the things that really stuck out of me
people made fun of my name that's all I
can remember but the idea that you're
like hey look you got to know how to
like Stitch someone up manage them make
sure they're elevated know how to do
these compressions you know know how to
open up this thing know exactly which
one to like you've got kids a variety of
things like kids or dyslexic they don't
quite know how to read They're they're
going in shock right they go into shock
they're not tall enough like there's all
these different things you're like okay
good luck and it's like we really live
in this world where it's like okay well
[__] the kids right like that's honestly
laid the mentality that Republicans have
but here's the here's the crazy thing is
there are people who are defending and I
saw in my comments and like oh yeah that
were like defending this and they're
like it's just first aid I'm like it's
not [__] first aid okay first of all
is yeah it's learning how to use like
Neosporin versus bacitrates right how to
take an aspirin how to take an aspirin
how to measure out like the various like
uh doses of medication not not any of
this and it quite literally specifies
Battlefield trauma care yeah I mean this
is why anyone would be okay and then
there were some people were like well
these are good things for people to know
yeah maybe starting in high school for
emergencies maybe but I can't even think
of what kind of I guess you could prep
them all for crash landing on an island
or something in a plane like I can't I
can't I imagine hey it happens a lot it
happens a lot listen I I took I took a
health class in high high school and the
funny part about it is we learned the
half-assed white rule sex education
thing we're like look this is a wiener
and this is what female parts look like
like they didn't really say anything
because it was too bad well I mean it
was a little it was taboo right and
we're all like I mean it's Missouri
though you know that's Missouri but
here's the thing here's the thing in
that same health class we took a CPR
course now but back then CPR you know
you did chest compressions and you had
to blow into someone's mouth now you
know you you you keep it you keep it
aligned to staying alive staying alive
staying alive I mean you know why
wouldn't you sing that song when you're
trying to I don't know keep something
you're like I gotta break the I got to
play the story yeah you got it yeah you
got to keep positive that hey maybe we
should make listen we should contact
um some some Texas State Republicans and
we should have them put in this Bill
yes absolutely that you have to sing
Staying Alive why
I'm just saying it's it's a good one
it's a good song and you can I mean to
have a soundtrack to be like well this
is the song that's gonna play when I die
it's a great thought to have right you
know that's one of those things where
you're like well at least I know what to
play at my funeral right well that's
true I'm not trying to get in writer's
mode but there may be a satirical um ad
there have you ever seen the ad where
they're talking about um uh I forget
it's several years ago it's a horrifying
ad in the end is it the one with the
school supplies yeah the school supplies
that that commercial makes me that's
like every time Bill this bill is that
in real life it is that's this in real
life all these like crazy like 2A
families really just think they need to
toughen their children up it's it's very
scary I mean if you look at the the
studies have come out about hardening
schools right we got to make schools
stronger and tougher you know whether
security cameras or fence I mean it
really is like Tony said you're creating
a prison structure here is what's going
on but even though with studies and
again you know Republicans have a hard
time understanding basic
yeah just you know not open-minded to uh
to acknowledging but even though there's
studies that show like
um resource officers or hardening
schools by bringing people in to have
guns or whatever actually heightens and
worsens a an active uh shooter situation
in a school right
that is what happened like that's that's
the truth of the matter is if you bring
someone in for a gun to fight a gun
right I mean I the idea that we need
someone to fend off someone is crazy
because we could even stop it at its at
its [__] beginning right by not
allowing the guns to be so accessible
and uh Tony yes stop singing they'll
charge I I feel like I feel like that
you guys are like are like hey they're
gonna charge you for the copyright I'm
like I don't give a [__] about the
copyright they'll just turn off the the
monetization on the YouTube Ooh big deal
I'm not monetized anyways because they
don't like that the thing is you were
off key so
hey what that's what I was saying is are
you telling me to stop saying because
I'm not even [__] good are you
telling me that they're gonna charge me
for the copyright they're gonna be like
we're gonna charge you for trying
the trauma of listening
you you now owe everyone else money
right for having an apology yeah yeah
everyone I'm I'm deeply sorry that I
went into the The Falls I'm not sorry I
don't give a [__] it's my show it's my
and and
YouTube Kiss My Ass monetize me and then
you can take my money away that's what I
say that's what I say thanks for joining
us I appreciate you bringing this
delight and uh keep yelling and
screaming
um I actually think this is more a rake
stepping moment our face planting moment
because honestly
um if we can get people who don't pay
attention to politics to understand what
Republican legislators actually are
trying to do to solve the s school gun
violence problem like their children
being protected by I don't know big uh
Battlefield trauma bleeding stations in
their school I don't think parents are
gonna be excited about that prospect
that that's what they're doing lock the
door
and have bleeding stations all over the
schools that'll fix it out of all the
classrooms rocket launchers and
yeah well you know I mean I don't know
but before you know
trenches build trenches in the
classrooms I mean that's what playground
time is for right you go you wake up you
know and you're like all right we're
gonna have a battlefield let's do it
proper yeah you're like this is going to
be just like World War II Gillian all
the cabinets in the classroom right have
it ready to go yeah why we're limiting
any of this we should yeah I mean
that's right that's right I think if you
put it out there Republicans like hey
that's actually not a bad idea and
you're like no that's the [__] ah [__]
man that's the problem because we live
in the onion yeah right this is all the
most ridiculous things you propose is
what they're going to really gravitate
they're like Ah that's a good idea
they're so [__] terrible at writing
we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania and real life that's where
we're at Gabe you had one more thing
that you oh no I was gonna say uh dare
before you go uh you have a weekly kind
of series that you do right yeah and if
you I don't know if you wanted to give
that a Shameless plug or you just wanted
to give any some other time or tell
people how you actually say your name
that way
okay so here's the thing though there's
probably a lot of people in these
comments who are going to get tricked on
Sunday and why why give them a heads up
let them just let them just find out the
hard way I uh yeah the the drag queen
prison hour thing uh yeah it's
showcasing all the
yeah the non-drag yeah okay
go to Darius account page it's at Dera
Fay uh f-a-y-e at the end and then uh
make sure to just check out look at just
this Sunday someone dropped yeah someone
dropped my link tree and every Sunday I
drop a video that that you're either
Gonna Love or you're going to get
confused by and then block me over I
don't care either way it's fine
well everybody I I I we're going to be
right back Dara Dara however you say it
how are you saying however you say
I'm just kidding Tony you canceled your
Camp I know please cancel come back
please come back and join us again uh
stay on top of it stay on top but we'll
see you soon my friend thank you very
much everyone stick around we'll be
right back
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show let's go to our
top story the headline of today Baker
Baker genocide maker
I haven't watched any of these clips you
sent it to me this morning I did not
watch it I wanted to be surprised I
wanted to I wanted to let the people in
the audience are you seeing my real time
reaction so he I was I haven't watched
this at all I was telling him I wanted
um Putin on the thumbnail yeah and I was
like what the [__] because keep in mind
keep in mind that Tony is two hours
ahead of me so it's like seven something
and I'm like just getting out of bed and
he's talking to me about something about
Putin and I'm like I have no idea what's
going on I just woke up so so he says
what happened and I sent him a few
tweets with the videos and I figured he
watched them but the reason why I wanted
to put Putin on there more than anything
is because I I just a couple times today
I'm one of the same to the microphone
Faker Faker genocide maker that's that's
all I that's that's all I wanted to do
because that's where this is going
um that sounds like a that sounds like a
[__] ass [__] move playing victim it
is well I mean this is what happens when
you start faking uh assassination
attempts on yourself so here's the
here's the Kremlin this is the building
you see with the Dome on it this is the
building that apparently a Vladimir
Putin resides in some of the time
um can you see the flags on top it's
night time you even see a couple guys
like walking up the the domes ladder
here and I'm guessing that ladder is the
flag ladder meaning that's how they get
up there to take up take the flag up
that way yeah
um that would be my guess and there's a
couple guys on there some people were
pointing that on the internet but it's
not going to be unusual
that someone's on these ladders I'm more
than likely like security and checking
so I don't think that's I don't think
that's awesome I mean hey when you're a
[__] uh you know war criminal
genocide maker right you're a dictator
uh there's probably gonna be a lot of
people that try to
you know you're you're not on you're
you're look you're not everyone's
favorite person okay and when you're at
this I mean we know we've seen we've
seen uh oh geez at the [__] Hospital
yeah so there's a breaking news is
shooting in a hospital we're gonna go
through this clip here now you can't
even go to the place where you would go
after you get shot well hey at least at
least there's professional bleeding
station people there you know I mean at
least this hey at least this active
shooter had enough compassion to tear
apart people's bodies right right inside
the place where they would that they
would fix them
um you know that's where we're at in
this country that that's the oh well
thank goodness
um where we're at um but this is this is
you're gonna watch and I'm gonna mute it
because it's not even worth um I'm
playing now again this is apparently two
drones were used in this supposed attack
again the Russians blamed ukrainians
immediately
um not really realizing the the missile
defense and the security defense that
the Kremlin would have in the first
place like they're they're totally
um and again this is just propaganda to
convince the Russian people that
ukrainians are actually attacking Russia
and Putin that's all this is it's all
[__] I don't give a [__] you can
[__] dig into it and see if it was
ukrainians listen if the ukrainians
wanted to take out Vladimir Putin in a
building they would at least make sure
his ass was in there number one number
two they would bomb the ever loving [__]
out of it they wouldn't send a drone to
try to burn the flag up watch this watch
as as it flies into the the frame here
um there it is right there and then it
hits oh boy yeah boy that was oh man
wait hold on hold on hold on again this
is the assassination attempt again I
have not watched this this is the first
time I'm watching this so much it's like
they dropped the flashbang right am I
wrong
or you're telling me that somebody was
like this is an assassination you're
gonna tell me that it's thrown that this
drone right however operated with
whatever uh or had on it was gonna be
the thing that was gonna kill Vladimir
Putin right like it was I mean it was
there make it someone someone on the
inside was gonna lift open a window
and guide it on in right well I mean
this is listen we're on a writer strike
so you're you're kind of you're going
you're writing a movie or a look I'm I'm
gonna by the end of the show I'm gonna
have a I'm gonna have a a a a pilot
ready to go oh really about should we
pitch it since uh I don't really want to
be a scab though I'm not I don't want
our accused of being a scam yeah yeah
but I think I mean like here I'll put it
out there writing that you're doing it
open source yeah open source open
sourced writing some idiot decided to
fly your drone thinking they were gonna
assassinate
or is it something else like I don't
know maybe it's all a lie and somebody
else uh from within the Kremlin of
Vladimir Putin said hey guys we should
do something that makes it seem like I'm
the victim I want people to feel sorry
for me I want people because here's the
thing then you're gonna get people now
on the right who are going to argue oh
my God can you believe what zelinski and
the Ukrainian did they try to oh they're
probably already doing yeah oh honestly
I mean like I'm sure if I went on to
Twitter right now go to Benny Johnson or
any one of those oh my God can you
believe he's ignoring the fact that
Putin has bombed hospitals okay there's
there's a big No-No out here they can
bomb the residential area last week and
killed dozens of [__] civilians right
and and this this is his attack again
this is his attempt of commit commencing
the Russian people that well because
here's what I think I think I think
Putin sees the writing on the wall here
and his only his only um yeah but who
wrote that on the wall well right um
well I mean not a writer well they are
on strike listen the um the the fact is
is that zielinski is not going anywhere
and Vladimir Putin uh thought he could
run him out of the country he didn't go
the um the entire country has unified in
solidarity around the idea of Liberty
and freedom and and and their
sovereignty of their nation and their
country and he is at the helm of that
and pushing that and I think Putin
understands if you if you keep zelinski
there this idea is going to keep pushing
it's not they're not going to bend and
genuflect to Russia and so this idea
that they would have a Ukraine would
attempt to assassinate Putin I think
this is more propaganda for the Russian
people to stay like-minded in this
effort uh to his lies but it's also an
attempt to justify Russia to attempt to
make a light an attempt on zelinski's
life here yeah this is laughable listen
you grew up in Illinois which fireworks
are not legal there yeah yeah Indiana
right well uh in Missouri or sorry drive
to Indiana in Missouri like in Indiana's
probably the same way like right across
the border like yeah if there's a sign
that says welcome to Indiana or welcome
to Missouri there's a [__] firework
stand right
24 hours it's open 24 hours a day now
um when I was a kid because it's
Missouri so they're like fire Works hell
yeah let's burn some [__] down let's
make sure people's arms explode that's
how we're here or there but you remember
m80s do you remember yeah yeah yeah I
think they're actually banned banned now
in most States but m80s like this is
what this reminds me of it's like a
drone drop the few m80s it I mean like
the
that somebody would be like oh my god
look Putin's gonna he's the like
Margaret Taylor Green's gonna come out
and be like oh my God the real the real
genocide King is is zielinski he's
trying to assassinate someone that he
has a disagreement with and it's like
okay [__] this ain't a disagreement
okay we got one guy killing because he
said [__] yeah I mean like you got one
guy Putin going into another country and
says it's mine and he thinks that
because he believes it's his that he can
just take it right he's like it's mine I
want right like that's it's it's it's
comical in it and and and it's in its
appearance to what's going on here and
so the idea that they're like oh look at
this drone that exploded you know uh
somebody I had it up earlier that said
that I've seen a bigger Flash from a
camera than that drone had because it's
true like
you are not gonna have that drone
that had that much like we'll say
explosive power to it gonna be the thing
that [__] killed Putin right and the
ability and the idea that they're coming
in at that angle like why wouldn't they
come up high and then lower down to the
area where Putin supposedly would be as
opposed to going over the Dome where
people are working right and they're on
patrol
and be like oh well you know what we
should just try to go in on an angle
like this and go directly in like
why would you where where are you gonna
[__] assassinate him where do you
think he's gonna be you know like do you
think he's going to be in his
president's new office at that time no I
mean he's not there here's the thing is
that
um apparently this building he he has
residents somewhere in this building but
he wasn't there and if you see the fire
the smoldering part of the fire maybe
that's why the guys are on the ladder to
go up and set the fire to be like Oh see
it set the building on fire or some [__]
who knows but again this is a weird ass
fake attempt um I I need to move on um
and I don't I want to keep um
trust me I want to keep mocking Putin
there's nothing better than mocking
Putin and miking Republicans who genuin
inflict the Putin but um there is there
is a shooting in North Side Hospital in
Atlanta
um it looks like there's the shooter is
still at large I believe
um I think is what is being reported
right now am I right on that can you can
you see if you can follow this dude to
make sure
um it looks like multiple has been
injured I don't know
um again much about the shooter at this
point they are releasing a security cam
footage of this shooter and I'm gonna
show it because
um if he's still at large they need to
they need to find this [__] yeah
I mean as of uh what time was this now
again so well this was 35 minutes ago so
but they said the suspect is still at
large well I don't I don't want to post
the picture and um unless I confirm it
looks like The Daily Beast has it I want
to see who else has this
um it doesn't look appear here in these
pictures that they have as of 10 minutes
ago the Atlanta Police Department say
based on our preliminary investigation
these are the photos believed to be of
the active shooter anyone with
information on this person so is this
the one that I um hang on let me see if
I uh let me put it on the screen here so
you can see it
um to see if there's a guy with the
hoodie yes is it this guy yep yeah yeah
okay so so this this is the picture of
the shooter so anyone near Atlanta
um make sure
um that you circulate yeah
and it looks it doesn't look like he's
carrying a rifle in this photo at least
there's another photo of him with a mask
on but this is him with the mask off and
um to me it looks like whatever's in
this bag he's got his hand in the bag
here so I don't know if this was right
before he started firing I'm not sure if
it's okay it says the they're
investigating so Atlanta Police
Department is investigating an active
shooter in the area of uh one one
10 so
110 West Peachtree Street uh Northwest
so if anyone is in that area or near
that area
get away stay away right this is a
really weird hang on um this is a the
the thing I pulled up she's an anchoring
reporter for Atlanta news first but look
at her tweet this is
okay it says Atlanta P police released a
photo of the suspected shooter at the
North Side Hospital medical building uh
in West Peachtree Street in in Midtown
three people were taken to the hospital
but it was at a hospital am I but I it
but it says medical building so maybe
this is like an Annex of the hospital
it's not actually the hospital it might
be like a clinic yeah there's three
other according to this live footage
right now it says police at least one
killed in Atlanta shooting three others
injured in shooting inside building
suspects still at large so if I were to
look up
yes
West
Beach Street Atlanta Georgia
uh
uh let's see what is here
is it next to a is it a building that's
next to a hospital well I think that's
what I'm saying Northside Medical so
yeah it's like when I look at this Annex
so it's like a clinic building right
that that's not a tan or it's got urgent
care it's got Urgent Care on the bottom
if I go over then you've got a parking
structure okay I see uh so it's just
part of a big complex Hospital complex
there and this is just one of the
buildings yeah North yeah the the
building itself says NH Northside
Medical so all right well um so ever
anyone in Atlanta
um please be on the lookout and um so
hopefully the police department and law
enforcement gets the shooter in custody
as soon as they can
um
and no more lives are are lost to any
more [__] guns in this country Jesus
Christ
[Music]
um
I just I can't it's the stupidity right
it's the [__] stupidity uh it's that
we can't figure out that it's the guns
it's the guns stupid it's the gun stupid
um speaking of stupidity and again I I
don't want to waste too much more time
on facts that we don't know for this
shooting we'll probably end up saying
something about it tomorrow
um but here
and Chad's a tick tock posted this video
oh God they're doing more of this stupid
magnetic meat thing man so okay I
remember remember the Magneto phase of
the vaccine yeah man I I used to I I had
I had uh [__] spoon sticking to my
face right so during the Magneto phase
of the vaccine hysteria they were going
to like city council and health board
meetings and [__] and they were they
were claiming that they were magnetic
and they were sticking keys and coins to
themselves not not that they would um
try it out on an actual magnet but the
coins and keys here I'll try right now I
got keys right here
no it didn't work sorry well I guess I'm
not Magneto yeah well but also that one
for like I've got okay look I had I've
had two shots of booster in the bivalent
one uh I feel like if anyone would have
[__] be magnetic magnetic right now
it would be me right but why would they
make something cool though is first
though also the idea that if I was
magnetic I would have [__] fragged my
computer right now right well dude have
you ever watched [__] X-Men who what
what power is cooler than [__]
Magneto yeah I mean Jean Gray is really
cool it's cool that you can read
people's minds the other thing more than
just that right the telekinetic Powers
but also she's you know considered one
of the more powerful mutants in the
X-Men right but Magneto hello he's like
the worst villain ever because he's so
powerful why the [__] wouldn't that be
cool but but I mean you could I mean I
don't know there are a lot of times like
oh I can manipulate metal in my my uh
relationship with it I can like even if
you were to use the movies as reference
it's like oh yeah I can use all these
little like iron in someone's blood and
I could pull it out right and then make
a plate that I can then just levitate on
or use or use metal to then you know uh
in in a sense like creating a sounding
board where I can move past it
levitating I could [__] fly if I was
actually Magneto you could shake the
Earth or the metal on the earth it's
[__] incredible what you could do now
we're we've reached another Magneto
phase in the Q Anon Universe here
because now they're claiming and they've
been claiming this for weeks and of
course you're trying to [__] get
through them like hey dude coins and
keys are not magnetic they're not try a
[__] real magnet off your
refrigerator and see if the coin sticks
to it yeah understand what a magnet is
and what sort of metals are because
there are metals that are magnetic and
some of them that are not magnetic right
oh it hurts my [__] head to even
think about this but somehow they've
gotten to where beef specifically from
Mexico is magnetic because it's trying
to manipulate you why are they saying
that beef from Mexico is
let's let's because right now I'm gonna
pitch you a Hallmark movie okay okay
here we go more writing on the writers
yeah these are all and no no these are
these are very shitty ideas okay your
right wing media wants to take it and
run with it all this is open source by
the way
look I'll even give this a challenge
to the audience if someone wants to take
some idea that we've mentioned right now
right and like oh yeah I want to make a
fun little video [__] send it to us
we'll play it on the show I love that
man if you guys want to create hell AI
it up and it's really bad I'll
definitely show it but here's here's
what I think's happened right
they're gonna say that cows right the
beef the meat that's coming into the U.S
that has been that has been exported
from Mexico they're trying to do two
things one taco magnito oh my God the
movie right there it writes itself so
basically what they're saying is that
these cows you know a little spicy the
the Sangre is a little spicy right the
blood and inside they're gonna say like
oh there's a lot of iron inside that
blood and if you eat that that's coming
from the vaccines you know there's gonna
be a whole movie where they're gonna
have they're gonna talk about how we
can't import the meat from Mexico
because you know our vanilla taste buds
we don't like that right little oh two
says nacho X-Men what kind of oh man
what do you call X-Men that's not your
oh yeah nacho X-Men right
um
they're [__] all over your idea
because they got some great names for it
I'm not no they're not [__] all over
it they're making it better right but
the idea the idea that there's these
magic magnets cows that are coming from
Mexico right the Mexican me I mean
[__] Mexican Magneto and the only
difference the only difference is
Magneto has an accent over the O magnito
Magneto we'll call it right
but yes the the Mexican Magneto meat
that comes in from Mexico right that is
what they're afraid of because they're
gonna be like oh no these these illegal
these illegal cows coming in they're
gonna they're gonna [__] ruin us
they're gonna make us all magnetic we're
going to be controlled it's
my God I don't know I think this is a
good one
um chips and Giggles I think that's a
pretty good one moognito
okay now I'm gonna show you a video here
this chucklehead okay so this is do you
know Stu Peters is is [__] idiot uh
so this was posted on his account so I'm
the real dude
Stu Peters he's got a show where he's a
dumb [__] right winger it just
sounded like a made-up name well I mean
like my name is Stu how does he spell
Stu s-t-u-s-e-w
s-t-e-w like a [__] like eating stew
go look it up shut the front door go
look it up but he posted this on his
accounts uh sheds of tick tock pulled it
and uh played it here
um he obviously was bragging about it I
believe but
um is it real it's real right yeah yeah
I'm just I'm just now I'm going now I'm
going to Daily Beast with an article
that says maga's new shock jock is a
bounty hunter with a troubled past
here's another what was that but here's
this lady that he's posting her little
video here yeah and and she's got a
she's got a pack of beef here it's
hamburger I don't know if it's like 85
or 90. I'm not really sure yeah how lean
is that beef baby it's certified beef uh
it's got a sticker on it certified by
who us yeah just Magneto I don't know
it's certified by the magnets watch what
she does with a coin this is [__] oh
my God they're outside their [__]
minds so video two so you don't think I
just videotaped it there if you look on
off it doesn't fall it doesn't stick oh
yeah
okay
you can kind of feel the magnetic pull
oh there it sticks the magnetic pool
because you feel the magnetic pool how
can she feel like what transitive aspect
is happening
she's Magneto now what what wait wait
wait so if so if she if she no look I
mean I'm not sure how this Insanity
Works look here's the thing is what she
is doing is she is claiming not only
that that this coin sticks to a magnet
which is bizarre at best but that in
this package of Magneto beef whatever
this is hamburger there's only one spot
inside of it that is magnetic like as if
a cow ate a magnet and then you grind up
if that's how it works you remember that
you remember the lawmaker that was like
if you swallow a camera it'll go down in
your vagina do you remember this yeah
yeah that was uh that was amazing
amazing intellect same same
people same [__] who think that
there's only one spot in the Hamburg I
don't know if they know how Hamburger
Works do you know how hamburgers made
surely you know how hamburgers I I mean
I I honestly am now questioning whether
I do know based on I mean you grind it
up it's ground that's why it's called
ground beef porous ground beef yeah how
would a crown beef if you grind a beef
how would I don't know honestly magnetic
I don't know and how would a coin that
is not magnetic stick to it I wanna know
I wanna know that it's possible it's
possible that watch if you move it it
falls off it falls off video two so you
don't think I just if you moved it
wouldn't it stay on
Friday if it's [__] magnetic if you
moved it it would then there's an equal
especially if it's ground up a ground up
something that's ground up or you've
mixed it together you're like great
there's an even displacement of this
magnetic power that's inside this meat
this idea that you would say I'm going
to move it from the you know wet part of
the [__] package wait it's The Wrap
it's the wrap it's just like it's the
guns morons the the wrap is sticky it
sticks man it's a little sticky and she
moves it sticky ramp what I just don't
get I don't get what she's trying to say
if it's magnetic then if she moved it to
any part of the package front or back
that it would actually work right but
what is she actually this is why we need
to fund public education what is she
actually saying is she saying the
government government needs to make sure
that that beef isn't magnetic so they
need to inspect the beef is that what
she's saying because people so she wants
people to [__] get their their dirty
grubby hands inside that meat what they
do they already inspect the beef I don't
know if she knows this but there's
Federal Regulations on beef especially
when it comes from Mexico
wait wait what's that sticker
what's it says it's USA certified oh
damn okay all right all right so well
that's the other thing that's the other
thing too is is that is that when you
get a U.S USA certified sticker it means
it was certified here so Not only was it
probably certified in Mexico because
they have regulations against the beef
but it was certified at the border when
it came through I don't know Customs
which is a [__] Federal agency and
then when I mean if that's your argument
be coming from Mexico and then when it
arrives not only is that is that beef
inspected before it's cut and made into
whatever ground beef are are Stakes or
cut that you're gonna make it into it's
it's it's inspected throughout the
entire process right it just there's
there's you you you can confidently say
there's a few touches
like touch points that happen throughout
the process of hey there's a cow we need
to then kill the cow and then we need to
take the meat from you know the cow and
then we need to grind up the meat from
the cow and then we need to package the
meat from the cow and then we need to
send that packaged meat from the cow to
the U.S and then someone in the U.S says
great we'll accept this ground of meat
from Mexico from the cow and then we'll
send it to wherever it needs to be
inspected before it then gets on the
Shelf at your where do you think they
put the magnets in it the 5G magnets
where I think they hide it at the very
end like you know you know that you know
when you go to the deli when you go to
the deli and you're like they're just
like pushing them in the ground yeah
yeah I think I think this is The
Butchers it's I mean butchers if you
think that's what it is if you really
think about it when you go to the deli
and you're like oh here's the fish and
here's the cut of meat right they're
never there in the front they're like
always in the back right hello always
have really weird outfits on like
they're all matching in white exactly
it's almost like like they came from
their uniform right like they're
scientists that's it and they're the
Deep State butchers that's what it is
that's what it is speaking of Meat Heads
somebody made that somebody make that
speaking of Meatheads
um it a meathead it's being confirmed
it's breaking a meathead uh was actually
testifying in front of Jack Smith uh
apparently Jack Smith himself sat in on
Pence Meat Heads testimony why wouldn't
you on the phone you've got this you've
got the I mean if we're looking at a
crime family Syndicate here
the fly on Vince's head yeah wouldn't
you like no I I'm sure the fly is the
one who gave Jack Smith the info right
he's like dude I was here for all of
this that we said what you're saying is
he said in on Pence's testimony and the
Flies testimony yeah yeah yeah but but
the fly came in and he's like hey look I
know we don't have an appointment right
now now Jack Smith but I just want to
let you know that I got the receipts
here let me play this audio recording
and then he played him and he's like
holy [__] I can't believe you got these
like dude I've been around this
[__] piece of [__] the whole
time let me tell you more and he's like
oh my God let me write this down oh my
God can you can you will you will you
have a deposition will you will you sign
an affidavit he goes of course I mean
why wouldn't I and then what happens is
Mike Pence comes in and Jack Smith's
like I gotta sit through this [__] live
in front I want to see this in person
and that's why he was there I think and
the Fly was also on Jack Smith's
shoulder so you're saying the fly turned
on Pence oh easily easily totally
totally the fly easily I mean the only
reason that the flag was with with was
with Mike Pence was because of the
security that he had around him right
right flies are you know and they're in
a house man they're [__] you know
enemy in the state man they're they're
[__] Enemy Number One and so the idea
that the that that the the fly on Mike
Pence's head once Mike Pence left office
he was like I don't know if this thing's
Really Gonna Go My Way and I'm gonna
have the security anymore and he's like
I gotta [__] bounce and I gotta let
Jack Smith know exactly what's going on
and he's the one who [__] flipped and
he's the one who gave him the info the
fly flipped oh my God it's two hours
already God damn it
yeah well we're gonna have to show the
uh the James River Church in Springfield
Missouri tomorrow you're not I'm so
surprised that stuff is just coming to
light yesterday right or this morning
like because it was it was over the
weekend Josh Hawley was [__] he was
like Hey look at me on stage mainly I
talked about how may unmanly he was the
other day
but but had you seen the footage of him
on stage not the whole I mean part of it
but the tank thing have you seen the
tank thing no but I just want to laugh
at Joey Campbell's enema of the state
um you [__] you [__] out there in
this audience are the funniest some
[__] ever you're the funniest goddamn
audience here in this chat okay you got
a few minutes I gotta show this [__]
all right few minutes okay this is from
Springfield Missouri okay it's called
the John Springfield uh Illinois no
Springfield Missouri it's um it's down
by Branson Missouri which is Branson
Branson
um Springfield is the third largest city
in Missouri actually a lot of people
don't know that fourth is Columbia where
the University of Missouri is I'm not
the University of Columbia or Columbia
University God damn it will you I'm
trying to get to the clip here so here's
the setup I've driven past the James
River Church a lot it's a big
[__] Stadium it sounds like a
Megatron it says well I mean Mega is
is kind of loose because it's not just
Mega it's [__] super mega like it
Ultra Mega Ultra Mega yeah mega church
right okay now if you're wondering
um how [__] fragile white males are
um and how insecure they are they had
this male conference thing whatever
Christian white nationalist Christian
male white yeah it was a bunch of uh
[__] clan members [__] right who
were like I want to feel like a man but
they had a tank they had to make up for
this I mean these are the same guys that
probably drive around with the big ass
lifted trucks the oversized tires and
the huge wheels and then they need like
a little step ladder to get down and
they never jump off it right they've
never hauled anything in their truck in
their entire life well the only thing
they have hauled in that truck is their
ass because that's where they're going
and they switch from uh a case of Bud
Light to Cooler's light because they
don't know Coors is gayer than Bud Light
but you know they don't know a lot of
things and you're gonna realize that
from this clip now this is the the manly
conference down the white Christian
nationalist manly conference
um it's [__] cringe-worthy but watch
at the end what comes out it's it's
laughable watch
[Applause]
oh that was [__] lame and [__]
[Music]
here we go
Jesus Christ
what the [__] are those live rounds or
those [__] fakes I don't know look at
this [__] what
that's what I heard that is what I when
he's like and here comes
it's like Jesus man oh man
oh my God I just like this is where we
are you know Dara was on earlier and we
talked about how we are living in the
onion
this is the [__] this is idiocracy
this is idiocracy this is it man this is
in the [__] movie isn't it yeah
there's I wanna oh actually I just
learned this the other day because I was
on YouTube and it got uh this little
like did you know kind of factoid got
sent to me okay everyone I'm assuming
has seen Idiocracy if you haven't please
go watch it it's a documentary on what
is our future so basically the premise
the premise here right of of they're
like oh smart people don't want to have
babies so they freeze them then dumb
people procreate and then we end up
where we are in our current timeline
anyway for the movie Mike Judge the
creator of Silicon Valley office space
that he's working with the um
the costume designer and says uh hey we
need you know we don't have a lot of
money so we need to find ways to to cut
and save on costumes and the costumes I
was like okay well uh there's a very
small company they make these very ugly
shoes
um we can use them right you're like
great okay cool yeah we can save money
there and then no one no one will ever
no one will ever like no one will ever
yeah no one ever will use these shoes
wear these shoes there's no way this
company is going to survive and Mike
just goes well what what if this company
becomes like popular and like really big
and the costume designer says no there's
no way it's gonna happen they're ugly
that's not gonna happen
the shoe that they use in that movie is
the [__] Crocs
and now you fast forward and Crocs are
having this whole [__]
Revolution right where now those are the
I I was just at a I was at a [__] pie
competition in in uh at UCLA oh what a
pike Jake Gyllenhaal was there uh at the
pie competition too there was a everyone
it was they had this like pie the KCRW
the local NPR
had a pie competition where people came
in and they made their pies they
competed and then you could also try the
pies if you were lucky enough to get it
what does this have to do with Crocs the
reason I bring up Crocs is because Crocs
were everywhere on that campus at UCLA
people were there with the normal Crocs
the [__] alien Crocs and [__] [__]
weird man it was so weird but while I'm
there I was like oh this is so weird
because just the day before I had seen
this video on YouTube about how Crocs
were used in the movie as a [__] joke
and now it's 2023 in real life or the
whole thing like in the last few years
the cracks are so great oh man I gotta
wear these cracks I gotta put the pins
in the Crocs for the kids I gotta do
this
it's it's it's a documentary idiocracy
is a [__] documentary and here's what
is happening and here it is here in real
life you know you talk about little dick
energy
like microscopic over compensation when
they're driving their big trucks around
imagine getting
um a rock concert together a hair metal
band and playing music and driving a
tank out um with guns and then driving
them over cars like literally this is
[Music]
the intersection of WrestleMania in real
life I'm so sorry I had to subject you
to that but that's what's going on in
the uh White fragile male Universe right
now
and we'll keep you abreast all all of
these um wild things and how idiocracy
is a documentary here on the Tony
Michaels podcast Newton Eastern 11
Central nine Pacific every single
weekday Monday through Friday 2
hours or a little bit over you know if
we gotta show a clip and talk about
Crocs and how um idiocracy is
documentary and now um the right is
overcompensating for the little wieners
especially Josh Hawley yes Josh Holly
was at that conference he was he was the
owner he was the headliner speaker there
that's to tell you how's the headliner
how manly that conference was that's to
show you if he was headlining everyone
else probably had an even smaller dick
or a baby or little wieners look at all
the little winners here man oh my God
Josh Hawley you are such a cuck and
everyone in that building safe space for
cuts oh I wonder if Nick Adams was there
who goes probably he was probably
snacking on his M M's and he's drinking
his Coors Light and being like Oh man at
least I'm not the only one with a small
dick
oh everyone come back tomorrow same time
same place we'll be doing the same [__]
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon